Oh
we will proceed with our next speaker
welcome everybody again work
- first parallel session and we're going
to have undress tribe up in the German
Aerospace Center and we'll talk about
quantifying ourselves we're very curious
let's go ahead ok saying so this talk
will not be due to technical it's about
quantified self who a few have heard
about quantified self or it's actually
some kind of a safecracker not too many
people that's good because I'm going to
explain what quantified self is I'm it's
about yourself myself so in its reason
why I'm also talking a little bit about
myself
you know maybe more than enough then
speakers and other talks - yeah and so I
start with yeah start over
there's an interaction of me so my main
job is I'm I'm working as a scientist
and head of department at the German
Aerospace Center or touch center for
Luther home fat I'm I'm leading the
department for distributed systems and
we work on disability systems naturally
high-performance computing and software
engineering we are located in Cologne
and banks like Anton in Berlin and
actually we are just behind couch off
over there over there there are offices
beside here I I confronted the company
Medano where we are developing like
mobile health apps for Android maybe and
I'm actually co-founded a quantified
self meetup group I will talk about
qualifiers have meetup groups a little
bit later
especially meetup group in Cologne
actually and yeah this is like a
conference more or less about Python and
I'm pison user since 1992 when I was at
University
I found out actually that the most lines
of code about him Python is for pi some
versions 1.1 1.2 11.3 so after that I
was well writing like finite element
codes and the stuff this and it at that
time and nowadays I only got small
chunks of code entering into ipython
notebooks it's more or less all so I'm
involved in the Python community I'm a
member of spicy noodle group in Cologne
pipe alone I was Chelsea last Pike on
Germany in Cologne which de la operates
and I'm chair after you PI HPC workshop
just in a workshop on Pais of
high-performance computing the next
edition will be in November 17th and New
Orleans in the US so related background
regarding to his talk as there to things
like his personal site and the
professional side the personal side how
I came to like this stuff 24/7 as I had
a stroke 2009 it wasn't well impressive
incident in my life I couldn't speak
anymore at the time I couldn't for my
hand anymore and to learn all these
things again and I had to take care of
my blood pressure and my health as a
whole so actually this was very
impressive and I started then at that
time thinking about health and tracking
health parameters and thinking about
training and cell P and all stuff so one
of the outcomes was that I co-founded
the company in bed and oh because of her
out at a couple of apps that I would
have loved to have for like training and
selfie wasn't available like for speech
therapy Mouse motor training and so on
so people at the rehab were kind of
laughing at me when I was talking about
apps for training stuff
so I just developed an app for that so
the usual thing so and at the large
Germans as I said that we also deal with
this medicine especially telemedicine a
lot this is mainly focused for space
medicine because you can imagine if you
have like people in space countly this
colleague of us absently as ISS
Alexandra is for six months and there's
no doctor around
so telemedicine and remote chaos and
very important topic in its base in the
aerospace so we deal with it since many
many years and my department is like
developing software apps in this field
like for telemedicine and it assisted
living this is targeting on more elderly
people and especially also we're
developing software for like space
medicine so this is the background so I
started with tracking my blood pressure
and all the stuff and then I found out
that there's a well like a physical was
a fizzle of a strudel like context of
this called quantified self and
quantified self is like you I mean there
are a couple of definitions one is it's
like self-knowledge through numbers you
are quantifying yourself you're
measuring things about yourself and try
to understand that so it can learn
something about yourself and sometimes
there's ego to improve yourself
sometimes just to have like insights or
so you can like record daily activities
like Wii Fitness sleep you sleep your
locations very common stuff actually and
monitor and display this information
from the rise devices so I've come to
examples later there are other terms for
that like some people call it self
tracking or life hacking life hacking is
especially if you are like try to change
something in your life with some certain
activities or life logging that's
especially where you are like
like making like a whole picture of you
laughs what you're doing especially and
things like sales optimization if you
like to improve yourself this is safe
optimization is very important for that
people who are doing sports professional
sports persons and so on a simple safe
optimization example is like if you have
been here the beginning of the week is
what was quite warm so people wasn't
drinking about we're drinking about a
lot of water and there were a couple of
cases of dehydration so this would be a
good case for like a safe
experimentation so how much what water
is enough to not collapse due to heat
you can like track your water and I mean
if you're drinking one one glass of
water in yazoo collapses of obviously
not enough and you can go on and drink
normal water and you find out what's
what's the perfect amount for you so
yeah of course EPS for that you don't
have to like write it on paper or
something like that's just a very simple
example the term quantified self itself
it's this kind of a trend currently it's
in the news quite often and odd at least
Germany and the US and maybe Netherlands
or the major newspapers had at least one
article about it all the TV stations
reporting about that and so on so this
isn't trend cough by Google Trends if
you are entering quantified self and
there's also kind of the regional
interests is very interesting the most
interest is in the Netherlands United
States Germany United Kingdom not so
much in other countries and so a lot of
quantified self groups meetups where
people are coming together and talking
about the quantified self technology
what I am measuring what are the
outcomes and so on so actually the
Berlin made ups were two days ago and
next we have been cologne is a september
force actually and cowlings are about
170 meetup groups
the things that your can track us is
very diverse you can like of course
track physical activities insulin intake
location blood sugar you troduce like
dimensions of your body I mean virtually
anything so you've work that you are
doing the time schedule almost anything
and coming the list of these words like
blow every day so the technology is for
tracking other stuff is also very a lot
of lot of things most things are
currently tracked is like mobile phones
and apps so the mobile phone is the most
common quantified self tool today a lot
of people using web and desktop
applications today and more and more
people are using special self-tracking
Hardware quantified self get rest or
whatever like wristbands and vice
dimensions I here - it's a Nike FuelBand
it tracks basically my activity from
moving around it calculates a value
called Nike Fuel which doesn't make many
much sense to me so I use this only as a
person clock but I forward to like to
step counter so many people also using
like safe made tools especially excess
batteries for that and still a lot of
people are just using a pen and paper
for for safe striking an important trend
currently is that there are more more
wearable devices that you can buy
so I mean County I don't know how many
wrist bands are available on the market
I listen Germany can buy more than 10
different response from those of
different vendors it really can track
your activity and also like arm your
pulse and maybe some other stuff so and
I think we be converging more and more
from like the human that we are now
today too like humans like volunteen
honestly bark or something because the
trend is now going from valuable devices
that you attached from the outer of your
body to implants that you yeah
put into your into into your body so
actually we are DL are also working on
that putting input onto the bungee bones
and measuring the elasticity of bones
and this stuff so my personal safe
tracking is like I'm using sensors and
smartphone apps for example the most
important for me or need it the second
most positive thing for me is that
counter for me company Fitbit Isis I
think that I've always here on my
trousers don't think it's the most this
is this thing especially from Vegas the
most precise things there you can you
also use of those fantasies not so
precise but it works too especially if
you are comparing the relative results
these steps if you're in steps the more
steps improving from one day to the
other
yeah I use it every day it's not like
that I have to but it's it's nice to
know the number of my daily steps I'm
not not saying that I'm a diptych but
I'm feeling not really happy when I'm
for fun I forgot to sing so actually see
yeah I'm actually measuring my weight
with the technology today is like a
digital weight scale which connect to
Wi-Fi and then sends the data
automatically to to the cloud of the of
the vendor offices of the debate scale
and then to your smartphone app and
there are other ways pens for example
just this thing W me they promise at the
camera trust your stress level this your
heart rate actually I forgot it today
but I couldn't show anywhere because
measuring the stress level is it takes
two NH three minutes for you have to put
your finger or less for three minutes
and wait
and you don't have we don't allow to you
to move for like a single millimeter to
any action so then the measurement stops
three minutes today you know our count
daily life is a very long time and so
this is not very practical for daily use
also I use this only for like
demonstration purposes sometimes or so
but I think this this thing of evolve
Santa to get better with the next
releases so I measure in my sleep this
I'm using and doing there's mice in this
one smartphone its sleeps next to me one
side of bed is my wife I wasn't sighs my
smartphone let's see setup and you can
see all my sleep patterns for example if
I've sleep well or not so well this is
also not very precise if you're going to
like a sleeping specialist or sleep
laboratory and compared to zero sites
it's sometimes very different but it's
good enough to get you in hint about
your quality of your sleep
yeah for me actually because my my
health is the most important value of my
back for sure I'm measuring this was
like regular blood pressure meters as
you can see in the picture this is
actually one of the apps that we were
developing in our company and I'm using
and analyzing this data the the how my
blood pressure evolved over time and
also I'm using this to discuss my
pleasure with my doctor and we we change
the medication that I get based on your
values and actually this F is like it's
not designed by software engineers
actually so my doctor and other doctors
I have to find the the analysis part of
these apps so the C reason why then
looks at the difference on other
platforms
yeah and for location and also for my
activity I'm using another app called
moves moves us own app from like
altering from Sweden now acquired by
a Facebook a couple of months ago this
is quite nice you can get a timeline of
your of your day the places they have
been at today for example if you this
wasn't like it wasn't in a hotel and
then go to went to an Hill restaurant
and it says me I was walking like eight
minutes went 30 minutes by some kind of
train and then walked again nine minutes
and it was it at the u.s. 1000 time and
we could also also map the same so if
you went going around it maps always
quite nice if you want to understand
where you've been in the past so like so
since a couple of months I'm also
quantifying my car suppose you can
attach to almost any car which was built
after 1996 you can attach this smell a
little adapter ODB di adapter support us
somewhere below the steering wheel it's
a small bluetooth adapter connects to
smartphone apps which are in the app
market and they also track you where you
are driving and your fuel consumption
and a lot of other statistics it is
quite nice especially for this app I
wasn't able to manage to export the data
to analyze to correlations with my as a
as a data but zetz plan so actually and
what I want to know here is come to our
drive differently when my stress level
is high for example or when I haven't
slept enough or something like that
that's the kind of questions that have
interesting as interested in so I'm also
tracking my mobile phone usage so my
mood this is the same combined app it's
from the University of Bonn in Germany
and it asked me like two times everyday
what is my current mood and it current
map does can can display this on a map
on location map and so on
it's also quite nice I like this app too
but I account we add a little bit of
data loss for this app so the first
months of my data are lost and people
from university I don't think they can
get the back from back up so I don't
like so much anymore
well I'm tracking my weight this yep
that's not so important and for
quantified self one thing is that you're
tracking all the stuff getting all the
data side topic is like sharing the data
things what are you doing mr. data
one thing that I'm doing is like I'm
publishing some of my data to a certain
Twitter account actually have like two
Twitter accounts one it's like private
and protected the other ones more let's
open the use cases actually that it
connects me and my values to my family
so actually my mother is reading the
values why my Twitter account and if not
that fresh is like a little bit high
frenzy immediately immediately caught me
and asked me what I'm doing if I'm okay
so this part of the effect Emma that I'm
quite alt now so my mother is still
treating me as a child so no and she has
no perfect vehicle to she like who
control me but I made it also the other
way around so I set up a Twitter account
for my mother special values amazos bait
and me and a lot of family members can
also control my mother and I caught you
wasn't once occurred hurt more than once
during the night when I figure out if
she was on the weight scale and weighted
more much more than the day before so
she get nice phone call to me - yes so
the basic principle and quantified
service compared to traditional domains
such as like telemedicine or so and it's
completely human centered all the data
is belongs to the human to yourself to
oneself you can like
that measure a lot of things like
productivity you can take pictures
Latvia LaBelle use the post activity and
so on the world around that is also
important like if you want to have
complete picture and correlate your
analyze your data relating to to your
surroundings you can also consider your
locations and the environmental data
whether for example weather so your
social interactions so a couple of
people are now I like tracking also
personal relationships and quality of
relationships and sex life or under
stuff you can also track your like you
get relationships on the injectors which
you dock and you can track your dark you
can track your car you can also track of
course and use data off from from things
in the ends of things in terms of smart
home you can use open data from smart
cities sensor on and the other side
assistance as well as if data is
actually going a lot of data is going to
the smartphone but actually many of
these data chunks are going into the
cloud maybe into your own cloud or in
cloud of different vendors of like
quantified self hardware tools and of
course if especially if you are doing
this stuff because of health reasons
then maybe DTD data is going to your
doctor or in medical medical center or
to your family or maybe to your health
insurance so that's that's use trend
that health insurance companies are
interested in your health data actually
for a test my health insurance is
getting my might step data actually and
other other health insurance and system
Germany are are working with this ideas
so a few words about data the data in
the quantified self domain is very
hideous we have data from the riverboats
other devices we have a lot of data from
variety from you to variety of
smartphone FCU environmental data social
data human data and so on and the store
should also also a true genius we have
local files and databases and of course
the cloud one thing that you have if you
want to like to analyze it you have to
access the data it's one kind of
complexity for many apps provide like
export functions and web services also
provide export functions you can get you
read as CSV files or exercise or
training files some services and some
especially however hardware tools are
providing api's especially if you see
data if the data is stored somewhere any
cloud unfortunately a lot of very good
apps actually don't have any export
functionality so I mean with good apps
it's in the sense that entering data
tracking data is very convenient very
nice and the possible outcome would be
very interesting but they have no NPI or
export functionality but yes from the
communities there's a lot of pressure to
this kind of apps to provide something
like that and another problem in this
all domain is set api's of different
vendors are very dissimilar so there's
no kind of standard or something like
that we also like any quest community
you want trying to change that a bit so
an example for web front-end way you can
export your data this is from the wound
dressings company which builds like the
generate scales and that for some meters
and activity trackers and so on so this
is this is like my weight so and you
have like a download button you can
either view your data on the on the web
or you can download and export your data
why is it web interface for example one
thing as I said the api's are very
different the at the it's kind of a safe
conference we were starting about like
get
overview of all the different api's say
look this is also from business the API
looks like that I'm not going into
details and for example the API of
another company like Fitbit looks a bit
different and api's for other companies
looking very much to where were we where
we are anywhere we're very different you
know and you have to give is it if you
if you want to build your own but
quantified self tools or problems to
analyze your data you have to deal with
very different api's and especially
people who builds like websites who
wants to attach all kinds of sources
they have many problems who said and
especially some of these api's of some
vendors I don't open you have to apply
to get access for example the Nike
FuelBand I think they are only counting
like true absolutely world who have
access to it so regular people like me
and probably most of you are not going
to get access to it to the api's that's
a bad situation to get access to do you
to get data from the API from pythoness
quite easy I mean for example you can
most most api's have authentication wire
or also and you can like West do escort
web services calls to it and for the
most common quantitative tools there are
special Python packages well somebody's
that's a Fitbit package for getting your
steps data from devices or for these
things so this thing's package it's
already on papaya and you can just
install it on your local machine and
import it and and you can get all the
data you can get your profile data on
that with a single simple call and get
your steps data this is from beginning
of the year guess what days where I was
working like 15,000 steps every day and
so on and of course you can like this
usual tools
you can you can plot your data and this
is very easy not very spectacular no an
apartment saying of course as in most
application areas and data and looks
today's you have to homogenize in the
data because data formats are very
different so almost every happening
every variable has its own format
there's no standardization currently on
one one problem is or one another
drawback is that you sometimes all only
get already processed data you're not
getting the raw data of these vices
usually they have accelerometers and a
lot of people would be interesting and
get you all getting zero exilim
accelerometer data and analyzes by
themselves and applying different
algorithms for it for calculating these
steps and so on but most most Venice
doesn't allow to get Luke doesn't allow
you to get indeed your data so there's
also a lot of pressure from the
community that they open it but it's not
happening yet and best practice what I'm
mostly doing is like importing the data
into pandas data frames and some kind of
working with it it's quite obvious
examples for this data as CSV export
this is forming Knapp called tap lock
that I'm using this app actually for
tracking my coffee intake every time I'm
I'm drinking coffee a personal button
and then the records make my coffee
intake data form adjust for the coffee
intake is quite complex it also records
the location where I am like one our
class in Colo and current Alexanderplatz
in Berlin and so on the record - GPS
coordinates
especially one data set has like the two
or three different time stamps you know
we have a GPS time there's a time stamp
here and yeah they're strong the time
again
Sep in two separate fields like EF
another timestamp and so on day of year
day of month day or free time of day and
so on I complex and very different to
two other to the data of other apps for
example fit but the activity tracker
here one thing some people who recognize
it is not English so this is another
thing you cannot influence if it's
English or German actually sometimes
you'll feel judicial redress that from
Romney you always get like German
keywords and from tabular headers and
well it looks different than you want
for and says also the semantics of the
world is not standardized yeah even if
you are comparing the data of different
activity trackers is very different very
nice example he moves APIs so they can
export very different format CSV to keep
drill Jason to us s 2 P X I can tracing
KML for Google Earth and so on and so
exporting like daily files monthly
weekly yearly files all in one file to
get all the data for example if you're
moving around here for BCC my hotel back
in or my my office he had was a look so
much closer it looks like that if you
use the export of that this is like what
I've seen exports just the places we
have been you can also like export just
the activity statue of doing you can
export a kind of a storyline so just one
single app can export where we different
file formats one nice thing was this app
you can just import the iCal into your
like Outlook calendar and see all your
other things wherever you've been in the
past week or in the past so I can now
have I've been Auto calendar for my last
one at half years of my life every time
I know exactly where I have been at the
time
an example for very different time or
lots especially sedate formats like we
have very different formats for fades
and very nice first technology that were
using was like like panas at said it
already handles a lot of these formats
like passing standard strings is very
easy or if the dates are separated into
different columns you could just combine
it doing important so like convenient to
use pandas for that actually coming to
analyzing and visualizing the data is
just is really essentially if you want
to get insights yeah if what does this
data mean does it data collate or other
data what can I learn counties a lot of
websites arising in the market like
single pays a tap and so on where you
can import your data and they provide to
like similar single correlations and
analysis functionalities this is quite
convenient for many people but of course
it's more fun to use like Python and
ipython notebooks and pandas for set
sets I'm not using these websites
anymore but I'm using like just ipython
for like single simple visualizations
for example distance like the
distribution of my steps like my daily
steps most of the days I'm working
around a little bit more than 10,000
steps so it's like on the far left side
you see you see a bar which about
researched about between one and like
thousand steps that wasn't period in the
last months actually assess the data
from this last six months this was a
period and in the last month when I was
in hospital and it wasn't bad all the
time because I had some problems with my
knee so I can can see this this area my
life also in these charts as a
correlations are things like like the
sleep efficiency compared with the
duration of my sleep so I found out that
for me my my sleep is not getting better
from sleeping longer so
better sleep few hours less and my sleep
is better sorry how's this
that's some kind of a death certificate
questions this is some kind of a self
rating of your sleep that you are doing
Anika this is a combination of self
waiting of your sleep and some movements
that you are doing during sleep yeah
you'll feel sleeping well well and
you're moving much less and you can
fight others of course like in typical
data applications that where you even
didn't know that there was a question
actually it happens for me all the time
so when I was complaining once is my
coffee intake data of wanted to like to
visualize completely different stuff but
then I found out this little nice bar
chart actually on the like 10 means 10
10 a.m. and 20 means 8 p.m. so on the
CEO of today and so I just see that I'm
drinking most of the cup of coffee in
the morning it's it's I mean some people
know that but I like it I like it and
it's for me it's interesting to see
actually on these charts that is exactly
true for me too so I can now go on and
like optimize that for example drinking
lots so much coffee late night or in the
evening or taking more coffee late night
or in the evening and that's the thing
that I want to find out because I'm not
currently working on correlating coffee
intake with my sleep sleep patterns and
so on yeah and a special topic which I'm
dealing with is like visualization and
data analytics or mobile devices because
many people use mobile devices for self
tracking some people are using only apps
they don't use any any web interfaces
and so on
and so I think like especially can't
even save apps should have visualization
and some kind of data analysis included
so and as I would love to do that with
Python so a requirement for that word
this is not food not really fulfilled
today is that there should be good
visualization components for mobile
devices I mean the visualization
components and visualization rival is
for an order I guess you can you can do
simple plots like that but it's far
behind the possibilities if you have
like this much claw clip of us okay and
all its your visualization language that
I that I really fully wrap actually and
that's that's a topic where we will
spend a lot of time and effort in the
future to improve the visitor
visualization components for mobile apps
and also we want to like use like to
diagram pipe and a cycle on also on
mobile devices so
numpy is no problem it's already there
if you're installing like frameworks
that Python for Android and key B you
can just use non pipe but I don't think
that pandas and cyclone have been ported
to to Android this I am out of it but
just where we really needed for
applications currently be using like we
are doing like prototyping all this
stuff data and analytics things with spy
so and I PI seen on the web or on the
desktop and then a colleague of me is
supporting this code to java code for
Android let's see--we how it comes
currently interwebs but we want to
change it to choose Python on D on this
side well so there was machine learning
this is also a special topic of like
data analytics for example for typical
use cases that we are dealing with the
spirit and behavior patterns for example
medication non-adherence is an important
topic of reminding people for measuring
things such as blood pressure or for
advising using people for advising
people to get some sleep now for example
or other other examples are we want to
detect stress and this depression some
ongoing research topic which is really
important currently we want you to use
it we want to do it was like heart rate
variability this wristbands and so on
and we want to detect like to present
based on the communication behavior on
this smartphone so if you are
communicating less that's an indicator
for depression actually yeah and one
example from from the delilah we are
currently developing is like we are
measuring cognitive performance for
example for pilots of four astronauts we
are currently developing a combination
of hardware and software that they use
do it during flights where they doing
asleep tracking and they doing it sytem
psychomotor feature a lens test
basically this is like in reaction time
test and the app it just not not to not
complete yet predicts their fitness
level for duty so if they are fitful to
fly or not enter predict fatigue during
flights so they making a recommendation
if the pilots should go to sleep for now
so on long term flights tell me and if
you want is just a little box that the
colleague if we printed out a new 3d
printer it's not you find prototype but
the test is very simple this is just the
demo which all see the data analysis you
can start a test then write to the to
the small lamp yeah
no it's not working that's always why I
hate online demos so you can see you
actually time 12 20 milliseconds says
it's not very good
it's with a cable this is not very
state-of-the-art today all these
quantified self get us they have like
blue throughs and this stuff and you can
see the it's designed for the cockpit
actually so like companies like
Lufthansa or Germanwings currently don't
allow Bluetooth in the cockpit oops
so that's the reason why it has cable ya
County I saw a few if you are like this
is an ongoing project for Lufthansa if
you're going to to fly with Lufthansa
like in two years Orvis Germanwings in
two years
please go down into the cockpit and
asked for the final version of this
thing say you have seen it at a
conference at PI data in Berlin mm and
what have we have 14 and say greetings
for me and say you want to try your Pvt
test again and I think most most of
times our pilots will will let you do
the test set yeah okay current research
last slide can research forces currently
working on like provenance of quest data
likely get trust and traceability in the
data and to do privacy audits
standardizing api's and we're also
working code offloading to like offload
heavy computations into the cloud so
this is important because these small
devices don't have very much computing
power and if you are doing heavy
computation on this slide
the memory memory consumption is very
high to prevent that we want to like
move computations into the cloud okay
thank you
yeah first thanks a lot anyways and I
think we have time for a quick question
um okay
you already alluded to Zee questions
what do you do with the data once you
have it and now I see two primary use
cases well-being medicine and one more
that's a lifestyle oriented yes missus
have optimization life story and it
doesn't work because I'm just tracking
the data doesn't really help you so if
it's not for your coffee example do you
really say oh I drank too much coffee
that I will change it or if for example
if you wanted to advise somebody on
weight loss does it really influence
behavior is it good to know but what do
I know and what's the next step does it
you mean does it change behavior or not
if you have the data available that's
the first step but then you have to act
on the data and just having the data
doesn't really help people who won't
wait to change the behavior so what are
you doing there is do your apps for
example advise people do you yeah again
some people some it's not only arts
advice people and many people are doing
or at least should do something of the
safe tracking also for like medical
reasons or these health reasons and
doing this stuff for self tracking and
analyzing or seeing your data over time
and especially comparing the data with
other people's data just this helps for
the motivation for doing measurements
for a long time this was a problem for
many for many domains the recent year
safety motivation was very lawful for
people who measurings us themselves but
just also new technologies apps data
analysis tools and social motivations
very high for people all right and thank
you again
you